[Musique]
hong kong
c'est l'histoire d'un revenant sur cette
chaise on croirait presque reconnaître
ferdinand marcos ex président des
philippines en 1972 il s'était emparé
des pleins pouvoirs et avait mis des
milliers d'opposants en prison je t'aime
ces acteurs sont en fait des activistes
politiques dans un meeting anti marcos
il qu'agathe sûrs imelda marcos les
pousses du dictateur déchu célèbre pour
son extravagance ces milliers de
chaussures et diamants achetés avec
l'argent public
marcos est un démon
il se moque mais ils ont peur car le 9
mai c'est le fils de ferdinand marcos
qui risque de devenir président des
philippines
trente cinq ans après leur départ en
exil l'une des dynasties les plus
célèbres d'asie fait son grand retour
dans tes rêves si jamais les marcos
cet activiste a été emprisonné en 1985
pendant le règne des marcos et
aujourd'hui elle craint pour l'avenir de
son pays mais son inquiétude est loin
d'être partagé par tous
et
[Applaudissements]
bbm bobo marcos depuis le début de la
campagne tous les sondages le donnent
largement gagnant le voici dans son
bastion du nord des philippines 22 km de
parade avec une foule ininterrompue qui
accueille son messie
pourquoi ça y est vous le meilleur
président pour les philippines
ne me le demandez pas demandez-leur
il ya ici beaucoup de jeunes qui n'ont
pas connu les années de la dictature
comme plus de la moitié des électeurs
philippin avec 6 millions d'abonnés sur
facebook et des militants très présent
sur les réseaux sociaux marco junior a
su convaincre la jeunesse
il est très intelligent et très gentil
envers notre peuple
mais il ya aussi des philippins plus
haché qui regrette ce qu'ils appellent
l'âge d'or de leur pays il ya 50 ans les
philippines était l'un des pays les plus
riches de la région aujourd'hui
l'archipel est à la traîne loin derrière
la corée du sud la thaïlande et même
l'indonésie je suis très excité géant
ibm jallet marcos d'où vient cette
adoration pour les marques hausse depuis
1986 tous les livres d'histoire à
l'école n'ont cessé de dépeindre marcos
pairs comme un dictateur sanguinaire un
endoctrinement anti marcos selon ses
supporters
après que le président marcos a été
chassé du pouvoir notre pays s'est
effondré ce qu'on raconte dans les
manuels scolaires ce sont des mensonges
ou
bbm 64 ans affirme qu'il est trop jeune
pour être responsables des crimes de la
dictature
il évite d'en parler et préfèrent des
slogans vague tourné vers l'avenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'unité du pays voici notre slogan
ce n'était qu'un murmure au début mais
plus maintenant
le murmure est devenu le cri de la
nation qu'est ce que les philippines
crient aujourd'hui n'ont
répété ce slogan
[Musique]
bong marcos n'a jamais été condamné pour
des crimes en lien avec la dictature
pour cet avocat des droits de l'homme
qui le soutient il n'y a aucun danger
pour la démocratie le fils n'est pas
coupable des actions de son père s'il ya
matière à l'être il n'y aura pas de
retour à la loi martiale
autre point fort bonbons marcos s'est
allié à sarah doute heurté la fille du
très populaire président actuel l'homme
qui prétend avoir nettoyé les
philippines de la drogue sa fille brigue
la vice présidence
bbm et sa race et l'unis team
c'est la meilleure équipe de leader
qu'on ait eu depuis trente ans
les deux familles sont en train de créer
une alliance puissante qui pourrait
gouverner pendant longtemps s'il
parvient au pouvoir le fils de ferdinand
marcos va-t-il réécrire l'histoire de
son pays aujourd'hui la version
officielle est contenue dans ces
archives gouvernementales qui recense
les crimes de la dictature
les histoires de ces gens sont tous ceux
qui font de la recherche ici
à partir de 1972 soixante dix mille
opposants sont emprisonnés 34000 torturé
et plus de 3000 tués selon amnesty
international
neuf ans de répression au nom de la
lutte contre le communisme et avec le
soutien des états unis
[Musique]
et marcos a dit oui nous avons imposé la
loi martiale mais c'était une loi
martiale bénéfique la paix et l'ordre
régnait dans les rues il y avait la
stabilité dans notre pays ça c'est la
stabilité ça c'est bénéfique non c'est
la violence du pouvoir que le peuple
philippin n'a pas vu
marcos junior dit que tout ça c'était
éventuellement les crimes de son père
en 1986 marque aux juniors était déjà un
politicien local de haut rang
il est responsable pour avoir propagé la
culture de l'impunité et défendu le
régime de son père jusqu'à sa chute
le clan marcos est aussi accusé d'avoir
volé à l'époque des milliards d'euros
d'argent public
l'une des plus grandes opérations de
détournement jamais réalisé
nous pensons qu'il ya de l'argent en
chine aux îles caïmans et aux états unis
bien sûr
elle demande enfin je ne sais pas s'il y
en a aussi en france
plus de 3 milliards d'euros sur les
comptes en suisse et dans d'autres pays
ont été rendus au gouvernement des
philippines selon les opposants de
marcos le trésor encore cachés auraient
servi à financer sa campagne actuelle